[Music]
all right
breaking news literally coming in right
now right now
fresh hives is today three hours ago
Oh today being what they made thirtieth
Saturday a woman has been charged with
attempted murder of four NYPD cops
during protesting what you do what
they're a Molotov cocktail police please
whoa luckily for her cousin her for
whatever future lies ahead of her the
cops got out safely oh so it's just a
tenant luckily for her to end the cops
the Molotov cocktail did not ignite what
did she intend to happen bro how about
that I think she's trying to kill
someone
cuz when they try to apprehend her she
and she's also being charged for
assaulting a cop because she bit an
officer in the leg yeah how did she
reach they're trying to go she went into
this knowing this is the [ __ ] end and
she's going out with the bang dude I
just saw like a cop car being burned
down right by the CBS building like
that's in what Hollywood or the valley
right man
that's this is on this is crazy this is
like a lot of different cities it's all
over the nation so it's eight o'clock
curfew today yes we yeah we got news
right today there's an 8 o'clock curfew
so like 5:00 a.m. or something like that
yeah a p.m. defiantly last night to a
protester unloaded 10 rounds to LAPD and
LAPD did not return fire oh thank god
she's like it could have been hugely
escalated I know because if they
returned fire man this whole city would
have erupted yeah this would have gone
livid that sucks for the cops to that
are getting shot at cuz there are I mean
a lot of people they just put cops in
one group and right now I know it's like
the tensions are high so it's easy to
hate on them but the ones that are like
that just came out of the Academy or
like young cats or whatever like they're
they're people too and if they hear the
order or hey we can't like you can't
even defend yourself that's like a
really scary situation to be in dude and
everyone wants to just go home and eat
dinner and be with their family like
yeah cuz if I was a cop right now I find
every excuse to [ __ ] up I think
oh dude that's why I'm not a cop man my
droid anything my pants don't fit
anymore I'm like sorry Sarge I don't
know where my riot gear way and I must
have must've misplaced it yes yeah yeah
the world is nuts man so like on like an
international level we had the covet
thing right and then like now there's
the Hong Kong thing and like China and
like I don't know what the [ __ ] Trump's
gonna do about that but China's like
don't [ __ ] know no foreign
interference with this [ __ ] we got
[ __ ] North Korea and like I'm just
like World War II World War 3 is right
around the corner it seems like and then
have you got [ __ ] Civil War a perfect
recipe for a disaster because we're all
locked up for what like two three months
now lot of tension oh there's a lot of
tension just even by yourself
at home we see all these crazy end
justices that aren't happening we have a
crazy-ass [ __ ] president saying crazy
[ __ ] it's like the worst recipe ever man
it's so like people can't wait to break
out of the house and like we've gotta
fix [ __ ] yeah it's just crazy I feel
like I have the best solution what is it
oh boy here we go everyone's been doing
that right so so what's the problem here
man I think I'm trying to do a win-win
solution and I think there's a lot of
sex workers out there right now that
don't work but what we can do is we can
use this government money right now get
the hottest girls in bikinis right let's
just ask the Dino nuggets company hey
man can we just like do this for world
peace right imagine in every
neighborhood all over the world hot
girls and bikinis are coming over with
Dino nuggets and just basically going
into protest going into all these
different places and they're spreading
love and imagine in the middle of these
poses these hot-ass girls just come out
and [ __ ] lingerie [ __ ] and they just
got mad Dino nuggets it's like I'm with
you but you could escalate things really
quickly because I'm thinking about a hot
chick with Dino nuggets and then
somebody bumps into her these Dino
nuggets go fine animal
thinking about goes at this stop oh
never mind the dialogue I see some real
nice and look at nerves right here
tender nerds maybe I don't know man I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to figure
out something right here's the problem
with that I know it's right
the the feet are still soggy even after
you put them in the oven at the
appropriate 25 minute timer and or the
feet get burned
you think sore burns you don't put them
in a toaster oven need a fryer the main
body of the Dino
is cooked properly but the feet is has
never been solved it's still an issue
well I'm just thinking of a food that
makes you think of childhood because
it's really hard to hate each other when
you guys are standing there as cops and
people hadn't had with Dino nuggets what
goes hand-in-hand with child it more
than jello jigglers jell-o jiggler oh
wait is that the [ __ ] leg little
[ __ ] bagel I don't know man cuz it
feels a little bit like like rape cousin
someone [ __ ] burns the top of their
mouth off and then they're all like mad
you got that Jared from Subway invest in
Hot Pockets TV I got it I got this I
found something that isn't tainted all
right all right
you know when the ice cream truck comes
by right you can only get it from the
Mexican ice cream man right so first off
that's very diffusing because it stops
everybody in their tracks when you hear
the ice cream man yes
and then everybody gets Mickey Mouse
popsicles it's hard to hate somebody
that's eating a Mickey Mouse Mickey
Mouse you hated the Jews in the 30s bro
[Applause]
[ __ ] John Wayne Gacy used to be an
ice cream truck man so the hand also you
said the best then it was Mexican ice
cream truck drivers for me was always
white pedophile so it's hard to be a
politician because no solution works one
of the pies there's no solution one I
want to be a politician cuz I think I
would make it work they would kill you
no don't barfi with the steak are you
sure as a heritage are you sure yeah
running on your die no no your nugget
platform I honestly believe that I will
they think Trump is bizarre right when I
throw in these policies they're gonna be
like oh your pigtail policies I'll be
running it's gonna be the pigtail party
so it's the fight fire with fire
oh well cuz the thing is you think this
is wacky I'll do this right but it's
just for the for the quick distraction
but then all actually come out and say
all right we're gonna really solve
corruption because I think that's what
we want to hear from politicians is just
not like hey we're gonna burn this guy
at the stake it's like so there's so
many more of these guys it's gonna build
a bigger pyre
there you go that's true
hey man now you sound more like your
advisor you should be read by there Joe
Joe the problem is there's not enough
fire Joe it turns out people aren't as
flammable as we thought yeah man turns
out we're made of mostly water we gotta
fix this problem alright maybe we'll do
the opposite if we're made out of water
let's freeze them to death you never
seen that [ __ ] happen I don't know but I
don't know it's hard to solve these
things right but I think the root of it
is let's all talk about the [ __ ]
corruption how about that everyone's
like we just need to get this one guy
it's a whole system that's [ __ ] up not
just one guy because this has happened
28 years ago see another guy replaces
that one guy you want to take yeah and
it's constantly happening it is theirs
I'm guarantee you man all these young
hopefuls that are going to the police
academy that want to fight crime that
are doing all these things they're not
going in
I want to shoot black people they're not
mmm I'd like to believe that most of
them are going in could they want to
change the world and they want to do
something good I would like to be banned
but I met a lot of these people when I
was in school and they're the type of
authority guys were like the [ __ ] have
to [ __ ] like Chuck you right now and
[ __ ] and it's like you they can't be
reasoned with or heard from like it's
they have their own mentality about [ __ ]
and they're usually very low IQ
unfortunately but I think what I'm
trying to say is that in all systems
where for example teaching right a lot
of teachers get jaded because they come
in and they're like we're gonna change
the education system they have all the
spirit right and then their spirit gets
stopped away by the administration and
the people that's been there for a while
in the politics they're the good ones
right and I feel like that's what's
happening in our justice system and the
police you know
the policing and all that and there are
some police departments that people
don't know they're infiltrated by gangs
and this is not a [ __ ] conspiracy
it's literally it exists plain though
for the people okay okay so aside from
like real mafia and gang members and
like neo-nazi groups or whatever they
there are people who infiltrated that
way
there are fraternities within the police
departments that operate as if they're
above the law
in many ways they compete within each
other and they have these cool like crew
names and there's write of passages that
are like you have to kill someone you
have to do this you have to do that and
they do things that are clearly illegal
but they back each other up and they
prey upon the the the system unit is
supposed to watch the Pete yeah the
society the the communities that are low
income and all that stuff and they're
involved in drug trafficking they're
involved that they're involved in a lot
of corrupt things but people don't want
to realize that exists people don't even
realize that the CIA is involved in all
that [ __ ] too right so it's like it
sucks everywhere it sucks because within
the department there's a battle going
internally like what the sheriff group
is what they're in the five figures
right there's like 30,000 cops or
whatever and the whole Police Department
LAPD
it's a [ __ ] ton of it's like a rape well
the good news is that
you have former cops who investigate
current cops
aka internal affairs and I'm sure that
there's no issue or couple there's no
conflict Mancha's there no way
well it's the whole rampart scandal
thing right yeah I'm just like I mean
that's nothing to see you here
don't worry guys I checked it out we
investigated it totally fine yeah me and
your dad used to be partners and uh I
made sure to look at your file and I
couldn't find it yeah still squeaky
clean as for what I can tell so what
would cause the checks and balance right
a third party that isn't infiltrated or
like in cahoots the idea hopefully of a
separate video government like having a
branch like the checks and balances like
you dish the judicial system that we
check out what enforcement's doing which
is what happens from the executive
branch like that's what we all hope for
but it's tough because I mean even if
you you know even if you got three
branches or whatever but like that kind
of mentality seeps into like each of the
branches that it's kind of like well the
checks and balances are kind of getting
skewed because everyone's you know
essentially decides to become be on the
same team one influences the other
executive branch appoints a lot of the
judicial branch so and that's all done
through the elections right so that's
how you justify it so it the system can
get corrupted at all levels from the
same [ __ ] place I want to play if I
was if I had power right so if I had
power and let you play this every single
day this is every video sorry the moment
that you said if I had power I just
imagined already a cape around you and
then you have like your big-ass crown on
your head okay okay let's tone it down a
little bit on a local level okay
smaller crown was mayor of the city of
Monterey Park right I know this shit's
going down but I want to get reelected
guess what dude I'm not gonna let this
[ __ ] go out I'm gonna hide the fact that
my police station is corrupt because hey
we're doing great arrests are up by
crazy we caught so many bad guys I'm
doing a great ass [ __ ] job cool
so there's something safer because these
statistics yeah and and there's so many
of these I feel like things were maybe
it's in the best interest of the
politicians to keep it under wraps
because they look bad hey how can you
let this happen under your watch right
I'll Bennett
career politicians building the resume
right and so I'm gonna do what I can to
look good not actually fix problems I
say we turn the whole [ __ ] thing over
reelect literally everybody in Congress
like it's time for turnover they're
serious turn over there did heavy crazy
clean sweep did what if no one knows
what they're doing now how about we
[ __ ] turn the whole [ __ ] thing
over and then and then implement people
who actually don't live in Washington DC
where they just [ __ ] cater to
Washington DC talking crazy right now
and live in their own constituencies
wouldn't matter would you make them do
that then they would be accountable
their own constituencies things like we
use the things that exist like
technology to let them vote from a floor
where they sought to live in their
[ __ ] community but they don't live in
the DC bubble where everything is just
DC time they could do zoom meetings
thank you we all have to do all this
[ __ ] yeah we could have live streams how
about when we all stay at home and don't
get paid they all stay at home and don't
get paid to that's time give me the King
[ __ ] what we feel for once yeah they
all have guaranteed checks guaranteed
payments their checks don't bounce they
don't care we have a caste system in
America but what ends up happening
though is like corruption in both ways
right because it's like if the
government isn't corrupting you and
giving you kick back what's ending
what's gonna end up happening is drug
cartels and outside forces will corrupt
you because you're not getting paid
enough I think that's the battle that
people don't understand is like okay if
you pay these cops 150 thousand dollars
right it's a lot better than if the
Mafia does like in Mexico there's
another battle too happening in
education right where all these
politicians will rail on anybody who
tries to advocate for letting students
take their money that they are allotted
for for them to go to school and put it
into the private school system all
charter schools at the same time send
their own [ __ ] kids to charter
schools
oh yeah non-stop full freight all the
time everybody in Congress does this
[ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] and they all
get to rail against the idea that that
the regular people could do it because
they don't want their kids to be in
school with the dumb kids is
what they think right which is why
[ __ ] Samantha be like lobbied against
regular regular public school kids
joining her kids private school look it
up it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's it's all classism dude but if
Dino nuggets and strippers came around I
think the world would be a happier place
I love it but the Dino nut the feed on
the dial nugget chicken nuggets then
like is the shape did you listen to us
this whole video looks like a Christmas
sock it barely even looks like a trace
here comes a tall
[Music]
you
you